belarus's President Alexander lukashenko
says his country has started taking
delivery of Russian tactical nuclear
weapons let's bring in journalist Julia
Chapel valova in Moscow for more on this
Yulia President Putin earlier this year
had announced that he would deploy these
tactical nuclear weapons to Belarus so
it looks like the plan has now gone
ahead
yeah absolutely and now we're hearing
signals to the world from the president
of Belarus Alexander lukashenko said in
his interview to rossia one channel just
yesterday June the 13th that Belarus had
received missiles and bombs from Russia
which are three times more powerful than
those dropped on the Japanese cities
Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945 he added
a million people will die instantly in
case that kind of weapons is used and it
wouldn't be a problem to use nuclear
weapons if a war started and uh now
talking about the deployment of nuclear
weapons into Belarus so basically
serious well the deployment itself
seriously changes the disposition around
Belarus this greatly strengthens Mr
lukashenko perhaps this is a condition
on the part of Belarus to enter the war
against Ukraine and here we go just
hours ago lukashenko did say that
Belarus would enter the conflict in
Ukraine if there was aggression against
his country so probably Ukraine should
build up some additional reserves along
its border with Belarus from a
scientific point of view the presence of
nuclear weapons guarantees the
territorial Integrity of the country so
any attempts to enter the territory of
Belarus will be stopped by the use of
nuclear weapons but
at the same moment having said all that
was still here a few very quiet activist
voices calling for the total elimination
of nuclear weapons on the planet Earth
because initially it was designed as a
means of deterrence but there weren't
some leaders directly threatened to use
it which can lead to the total
Destruction of the world's population
something needs to be done indeed Yulia
thank you very much Julia chapoval of
our live there in Moscow